oh my god I'm so scared right now hey
hey is that fun hi my name is Kelsey
rose and I hate cats
it's hates you strong of a word I don't
really like cats that much I'm gonna
hang out with cats I love dogs and cats
are not dogs they tear everything up
they don't really love you I'll never
forget it's a little black cat just when
you'd think everything was fine Shh I
want a pet like we both want okay so I'm
willing to try this cat see how it is
and see if I like it
oh there's option chicken piccata
yes pooper scooper that's your job I
don't know anything about how to take
care of a cat I don't know what I've
gotten myself into and she does right
under the couch oh this is gonna be hard
come on little buddy I've been laying on
the floor trying to get her out from
under the couch for like almost an hour
she's like sprinting running up I played
hard to get and now she wants to hang
out with me okay yeah we're gonna have a
pretty fun week don't you think
okay hi baby steps baby steps
oh she hasn't done anything wrong
but she looks mischievous well that is
meeting a fella for the person what you
doing over there
wonderful the hair on my clothes is real
mushy she's like crazy and my feet are
this other stuff that looks really fancy
so her whole change has been like in
this food look-alike washer
he's a baby cat baby cats are insane I
had no idea
Oh God out out out the first day I
wouldn't let her sleep in the bed by the
second day she wasn't that snuggling
that's so not fair look who's friends
good morning everyone I said you
couldn't be on the bed this is all I
wanted look at this guy
listen to him I see a lot of couples
bring a pat into the relationship it
makes a little family
after one week I'm in love with this
little guy did we have a good week
oh-oh-oh Klaus out Oh God
you're not a cat person until you get a
cat I think that that's just the truest
thing I've heard in a while
to see him look like a cute little cat
he would just like cuddle her just play
I've never seen that I just feel like
I'm a new mother now the times when I
could just relax and only worry about
myself are over he's the one who had
like the cute little voice in the
beginning and then I would catch myself
doing it
I hate admitting it but yeah I totally
fell for this guy it was love at first
sight
you know so was it was there was no
question for me who was gonna be taking
me home the cat has to make the person
as much as the person picks a cat see
there's a tongue thing like there's
nothing to eat silly goose I decided to
adopt I got a key
Paul D this is Mildred and she's pretty
awesome
okay oh that's my boob let's not